this moment really was about for me not
about anybody else it was about me
realizing i was good
on my own and happiness starts within me
and once i realized that things happen
jennifer lopez is choosing happiness the
singer opened up to apple music one
about her current season in life
after calling off her engagement to alex
rodriguez
and rekindling her romance with ben
affleck shortly after
things happen that you don't expect to
ever happen
you know what i mean you just like once
you get good
once you get to the point where you're
like this is not right for me or
this doesn't feel good or i need to make
an adjustment here this is not really
about anybody else but me
once you do that stuff starts falling
into place
jlo added that however uncomfortable it
might be
sometimes change is necessary sometimes
you have to change direction
even though that might be painful or it
might be
you know seem weird to other people it's
really just about who you are and what
feels right to you
and all that is echoed in the lyrics for
her latest single cambia el paso
which means change the step a song
that's all about starting a new chapter
and going in a new
[Music]
the direction of two ultimately realized
she wants to grow
evolve and stay true to herself staying
present in the moment
and enjoying all of the wonderful things
that are happening right now
meanwhile things are continuing to heat
up between jlo and ben
a source recently told et that their
friends wouldn't be surprised if they
moved in together
and ultimately end up together i'm
thrilled well they're spending all of
their free time together
and making each other a priority j-lo
falls hard and has certainly done the
same with ben again this time around
bennefer recently rekindled their
romance 17 years after their split in
2004.
i think we had chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working
and the couple's blended family
continues to bond
on july 9th ben his son samuel j.lo and
her daughter emmy
were spotted looking really happy
together during a family outing
feels really good and it's really nice
an onlooker told et that the group was
enjoying their time at the brentwood
country mart in los
angeles as they were walking through the
parking lot jlo turned around
smiled and waved at fans who were taking
photos
yeah i'm ready i'm excited about it and
as if they couldn't be any cuter
ben held the car door open for jlo and
the kids as they left
this is a beautiful thing seems like jlo
has definitely changed the step in a
happy and wonderful direction
she deserves that she works hard she
deserves to have something for herself